peu
[Musique]
monsieur le tribunal criminel
garde faites entrer l'accusé
accusée levé vous dites vos noms et
prénoms zecchini etienne quel est votre
âge 50 ans monsieur le président votre
nationalité
je suis italien votre profession
hôtelier je possède l'hôtel de l'europe
avenue des acacias
je les ai répondants un crime horrible
ce qu'ils nient vous êtes accusé d'avoir
assassiné votre femme et votre plus
jeune fille dans la nuit du 12 au 13
novembre 1926 ce n'est pas moi qui ai
fait ça je le jure je suis innocent je
le répète depuis deux ans vous avez 50
ans quel âge a votre femme 38 ans chez
président quelle était sa nationalité
italienne
quel âge est elle lorsque vous l'avez
rencontré 22 ans monsieur casino comment
avez-vous fait sa connaissance
en passant devant le merle blanc qui
était un café elle était sur le pas de
la porte
nous avons causé de quelle profession à
exercer tel à cette époque elle était
femme de chambre
et vous moi j'étais garçon boucher dans
la journée et le soir j'étais serveurs à
l'hôtel de l'europe
ceci se passait en 1911
cinq ans plus tard on vous retrouve
propriétaire non seulement d'une
boucherie mais de l'hôtel vous étiez
entré comme serveur c'est exact du
président
je bouge beaucoup travaillé et
m'apportes aux femmes aussi
beaucoup travailler c'est un fait mais
le travail seule n'explique pas une
ascension aussi rapide
comment être feu devenu propriétaire de
l'hôtel de l'europe
eh bien il faut que je vous dise que
l'hôtel était très mal tenu par un
certain millières ils nous paient pas
très régulièrement aux salaires c'est
vrai et pour compenser sa négligence ou
majorié les notes des consommateurs au
le moins possible monsieur le président
juste pour me payer
bref en 1916 l'hôtel de l'europe vous
appartient c'est un hôtel de 70 chambres
situé à 300 mètres du casino on ne peut
pas dire que ce soit une bien propre
situation
heureusement pour nous j'avais gardé ma
boucherie qui me faisait vivre l'hôtel
était dirigée par ma femme qui n'était
pas encore votre épouse un effet je me
suis marié à la fin de l'année 1916 pour
régulariser et pour reconnaître mes
enfants avant de partir à la guerre
combien d'enfants aviez-vous de
marguerite qui avait 5 ans lorsque nous
sommes mariés et joséphine kahn avait
trois les deux autres sont nés après la
guerre
sous quel régime vous êtes vous mariée
sous le régime de la communauté monsieur
le président lorsque vous êtes revenu de
la guerre aux affaires marchaient bien
n'est ce pas je n'ai jamais dit le
contraire
ma femme était très laborieuse pourtant
aussitôt votre retour les disputes ont
commencé mais même les violences aux
nous nous attaquions pour une question
de travail mais c'est tout votre femme
vous reprochez votre avarie
quand on commence monsieur le président
il ne faut pas jeter l'argent par les
fenêtres
certes mais votre avarice paraît avoir
augmenté en même temps que votre fortune
ma femme avait des toilettes neuf tous
les ans vous êtes un homme violent vous
battiez votre femme non
gestion vif l'un et l'autre mais rien de
plus vous serez contredit sur ce point
le 12 novembre jour du crime
n'avez vous pas une violente discussion
avec votre femme dans le cours de
l'après midi violente
non monsieur le président vous
reconnaissez avoir eu une discussion
oui mais sans violence à quel sujet je
ne sais pas moi probablement pour une
question de travail c'est tout ce que
vous voulez dire
c'était sans importance monsieur le
président que vous faites dans la soirée
nous avons dîné ma femme et moi avec les
enfants avec deux de vos enfants
oui des aînés était en pension après
dîner ma femme accoucher s'est arrimé
pépine puis elle est allée voir sa soeur
et son beau frère monsieur madame
gallone que nous avions comme concierge
à l'hôtel tirez vous fait prendre à
votre femme était avec sa serre et votre
beau faire je suis allé au café de
l'europe prendre une infusion
ensuite je suis me monte me coucher il
était 10 heures
un quart d'heure après j'ai entendu ma
femme qui rentrait il est nécessaire que
messieurs les jurés connaisse exactement
les lieux du crime
notre femme couchait dans la chambre
numéro de 32 avec ses enfants
et vous
moi dans celle d'à côté monsieur
président ces deux chambres communiqué
tél oui j'avais remplacé la porte par un
rideau depuis combien de temps
faisiez-vous chambre à part depuis trois
mois environ
et pour quelle raison parce que ces
arènes étaient revenus à la maison je ne
comprends pas quand c'est harry n'était
à la pension je couchais avec ma femme
depuis qu'elle était revenue chez nous
c'est à rhisnes dormait dans le lit de
ma femme à votre place oui il ne
pourriez vous couchez césarine dans une
autre pièce
elle avait peur qu'ils avaient peur
césarine n'était ce pas plus de votre
femme qui avait peur de qui vous je n'en
vois pas la raison n'est ce pas vous
vous obliger à coucher dans une autre
pièce que madame zecchini pour les
césariennes dans son lit ça ne l'a
jamais dit monsieur président tout
d'abord les messieurs les jurés
d'examiner le plan qui leur a été remis
voici que moi la famille et qui n'y
étaient répartis au commencement de la
nuit du 12 au 13 novembre 1926 l'accusé
s'était couchée dans cette chambre que
celle rideau sépare de la chambre 32
dans la chambre 32
il y à deux lits dans le plus petit dans
mes pepino qui avait trois ans à
l'époque dans le grand dôme et madame
zecchini et sa fille maintenant dit ce
qui s'est passé selon vous eh bien j'ai
été réveillé par un grand cri je me suis
précipitée et j'ai trouvé ma femme
debout au pied du lit tout sanglante les
mains sur le ventre
je lui ai dit
qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont fait elle m'a
répondu
l'assassin dans le vestibule
j'ai couru dans le couloir jusqu'à
l'ascenseur mais il n'y avait personne
je suis revenu dans la chambre
j'aidais ma femme à s'étendre sur le
canapé j'appelais au secours c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai vu césarine tout
sanglante elle aussi dans le grand lit l
agité son petit braz
c'était affreux sur président moh fight
arrive et me fasse et le plf qui est de
l'hôtel monsieur gérer sa chambre située
juste au dessus de celle de madame écrit
vous disiez mofaz est arrivé oui il a
pris la petite mon beau frère est arrivé
aussi
je lui ai dit d'appeler le docteur et
pis je suis allé prévenir la police
quand je suis revenu à notre tête ma
femme était morte
la petite fille aussi confrontons votre
récit avec le plan des lieux pour entrer
dans la chambre de votre femme
il n'ya en principe trois moyens d'accès
l'assassin aurait pu passer par votre
chambre
mais votre porte était fermée à clé la
sma oui je vais même laissé la clé dans
la serrure
on ne pouvait donc ouvrir votre porte
quand la force ans évidemment ce qui n'a
pas et reste deux autres moyens d'accès
la fenêtre et la porte de la chambre de
votre femme qui donne dans le vestibule
la fenêtre est grillagé et le grillage
se soulèvent uniquement de l'intérieur
personne n'a donc pu entrer par la
fenêtre
quant à la porte et est elle ouverte
lorsque vous vous êtes précipité dans le
vestibule pour courir après la salle non
elle était fermée aux verrous était ce
un verrou comment on pouvait ouvrir de
l'extérieur
non c'était une target vous reconnaissez
donc personne en dehors de vous n'a pu
pénétrer dans la chambre de votre femme
je ne reconnais rien du tout monsieur le
président je dis la vérité
et puis c'est moi qui vous ai appris que
la chambre de ma femme était fermée de
l'intérieur
j'aurais pu vous dire qu'elle était
ouverte non vous ne pouvez plus le dire
à moins de vous contredire car vous avez
déclaré au commissaire de police la nuit
même du crime
que vous ayez trouvé cette porte fermée
de l'intérieur
oui je les dis parce que c'était la
vérité
c'était en tout cas une vérité qui ne
gênait pas votre thèse puisque vous
infirmiers au même moment que votre
femme s'était suicidé après avoir
poignardé sa fille
je n'ai rien affirmer du tout monsieur
le président j'ai essayé d'expliquer les
choses quand le commissaire m'a dit vous
voyez bien que personne n'a pu entrer
dans cette chambre en dehors de vous
comme je savais que ce n'était pas moi
j'ai pensé que ma femme avait dû se
suicider et pourquoi aurait-elle tué son
enfant et moi pourquoi l'aurais-je tuer
nous vous le dirons prochainement ce ne
sera pas la vérité monsieur le président
si votre femme s'est suicidée comment
expliquez vous qu'on ait retrouvé le
couteau sous un meuble du salon si on la
trouvait là c'est que quelqu'un d'y amis
mais ce quelqu'un ce n'est pas moi voilà
ce que je sais vous voulez vous dire je
n'ai jamais vu ce couteau avant
l'instruction
quand j'ai vu ma femme tout semble lente
quand je les prix dans les bras je n'ai
pas cherché le couteau ils pouvaient
être par terre c'est possible je n'en
sais rien mais quand je suis allé
prévenir la police quelqu'un a pu le
prendre pour le jeter sous un meuble
uniquement pour faire du tort pour faire
croire que j'étais l'assassin je n'ai
pas que des amis chez moi c'est le
président
une utilisation bien grave et kenny si
vous soupçonnez quelqu'un d'une telle
imagination nommé le ce n'est pas à moi
de découvrir les coupables dans ce cas
n'accusez pas je n'accuse personne
je me défends monsieur le président je
n'ai jamais touché à ce couteau de quel
côté du lit votre femme avait l'habitude
de se coucher
du côté gauche près du lit de peppino la
nuit du drame
votre femme n'a pas pris sa place
habituelle elle s'est couchée dans la
partie droite cully césarine dans la
partie gauche
c'est là que mofaz l'a trouvée vivante
encore mais poignardé c'est à rim
dormait donc à la place où d'habitude se
trouvaient sa mère
si bien que tromper par l'habitude
l'assassin a tué l'enfant incroyants tué
la femme alors la femme s'est réveillée
en sursaut
elle a sauté du lit lutins bref pas
encore ce qui explique pourquoi votre
chemise était couverte de sang lorsque
vous vous êtes présenté au commissariat
de police non monsieur le président
c'est quand j'ai pris ma femme dans les
bras que je me suis mis du sang partout
il n'y a pas un mot de vrai dans tout ce
que vous venez de dire
l'accusation estime que c'est ainsi par
méprise vous avez tuer votre fille
non n'est ce pas d'ailleurs pour
devancer cette accusation que vous avez
déclaré au commissariat le matin même du
crime
quand ma femme s'est mise au lit j'ai
entendu qu'elle ne se couchait pas sa
place habituelle
non non et puis fait de moi ce coup
ce n'est pas moi que c'est le malheur je
n'ai pas tué ma femme je n'ai pas tué ma
fille
maillant est clean whissell avait pu
entrer dans la chambre des victimes dit
la vérité a volé non je n'ai pas tué
huissier fait entrer le premier témoin
parce que ma femme
juré de dire la vérité toute la vérité
rien que la vérité de parler sans haine
et sans crainte lever la main droite dit
je le jure je lui ai dit vos nom prénom
âge et profession me fall gilles 52 ans
cafetiers cafetiers oui je tenais le
café de l'hôtel de l'europe où se
trouvait votre chambre juste au dessus
au dessus de la chambre des acquis ni
oui mais c'est le président comment avez
vous été réveillée dans la nuit du 12 au
13 novembre
je n'ai pas été réveillé je n'en remets
pas que faisiez-vous n'ont rien mais il
y avait des chats qui miaulait cette
nuit là ça m'empêchait de dormir
vers 2 heures j'ai entendu des cris
juste en dessous
j'ai enfilé un pantalon et je suis
descendu qu'avez vous vu lorsque vous
êtes entré dans la chambre
c'était terrible terrible madame
cecchini était allongée sur le canapé
c'est qu'ils n'y étaient à genoux à côté
d'elle et il avait du sang partout sur
le lit césarine était couchée criaient à
peine en agitant ses mains et le petit
pepino assis sur son lit regarder tout
ça j'ai pris césarine dans mes bras et
je les portais dans ma chambre
elles étaient toutes mutilés
elle est morte aussitôt sans parler sans
parler hausse
c'était poudre en table avoir à présent
à transporter ces arrive dans votre
chambre
qu'avez vous fait rien je vais regarder
mourir et après je me suis évanoui
pendant que vous étiez dans la chambre
l'idée vous est elle venue de rechercher
la route du crime
ah non j'ai pas pensé
je vous remercie vous pouvez vous
retirer suivant cadeaux marcel 22 ans
cuisinier vous êtes cuisinier à l'hôtel
de l'europe
oui monsieur le président comment avez
vous appris que madame etc ligne et sa
fille avaient été assassinés c'est le
bruit qui m'a réveillé les cris non le
bruit congrès c'est vous qui avez
retrouvé l'armé du crime
oui sur le buffet du salon à quelle
distance le salon se trouve-t-il de la
chambre de madame zecchini à une
vingtaine de mètres ce qui exclut le
suicide m pas du tout je ne comprends
pas permettez monsieur le président
quelle heure est il lorsque vous avez
trouvé le couteau
il était 4 heures du matin environ vous
avez donc fait cette découverte
une heure et demie après le crime entre
temps le couteau a pu facilement être
ramassé près du corps de madame zecchini
par une personne mal intentionnée qui
pour faire croire aux crimes auraient
caché larmes sous le buffet du salon
je la hais de la plaidoirie maître en
sommes encore aux débats huissier
présenter auto témoins
je les reconnais tout de suite c est un
couteau de la cuisine ou l'orangé vous
d'habitude dans le tiroir au plus tôt
c'est dans ce tireur qu'il a été pris
par la sacem naturellement le croire et
est même restée entrouverte
c'est donc à l'aide d'un couteau de
l'hôtel que le crime a été commis
messieurs les jurés doivent savoir que
les empreintes nécessairement laissé par
le criminel sur le manche du couteau
n'ont pas été relevés
c'est là encore une négligence
impardonnable de l'instruction je vous
remercie vous pouvez vous redire le
témoin suivant duprat léon agents de
police 47 ans vous étiez de service la
nuit du 12 au 13 novembre
oui monsieur le président j'ai tu es de
service au commissariat nous était
présent lorsque zecchini est arrivé oui
monsieur le président comment était-il
habillé il avait du sang partout
ce n'est pas ce que je vous demande
comment était-il à billets et il avait
juste un veston sur sa chemise de nuit
et je ne sais même pas s'il avait un
pantalon par étiez de calme ou exalté en
une année l'autre ils avaient l'air
d'une brute
lorsque vous êtes arrivé à l'hôtel
madame zecchini j vettel a encore pour
ainsi dire plus avez vous essayé de
l'interroger
c'était plus possible la petite fille
était encore vivante
non elles étaient toutes couvertes de
sang on ne voyait que du rouge et lui il
regardait ne pleurais même pas ou
n'avaient même pas laisser de temps
pleurer
parlait-il et le répétait c'est du beau
travail c'est du beau travail à
l'instruction le témoin a déclaré
zecchini prononcer des paroles
incohérente
il répétait c'est du beau travail c'est
du beau travail en oubliant aujourd'hui
de rappeler l'incohérence des propos
d'eux et qui nie le témoin sans le
vouloir dans des formes le sens j'ai
bien regardé sa tête à ce moment là il
avait l'air d'un assassin plus que d'un
père de famille est ce vraiment votre
impression vous donner la question je
voudrais que le témoin nous dise si
c'est spontanément ou non qu'ils
trouvent à l'accusé 1ère d'assassins a
bien entendu chez spontanément personne
ne vous avez déjà pensé que c'est inique
pouvait être d'assassins alors c'est le
témoin a déclaré au commissariat que
lorsqu'il est entré dans la chambre du
crime gallone gallone c'est le beau
frère de l'accusé gallone lui avait dit
c est fini l'assassin c'est exact mais
n'empêche qu'il avait bien l'air d'un
assassin quand je lui ai dit monsieur au
commissariat il n'a rien dit trouvez ça
normal d'être arrêté arrivé au
commissariat je lui ai dit ce sétois
l'assassin mais n'a rien répondu
et ça marche voire balbutiait c'est tout
et après quand j'étais enfermé en
cellule et il répétait ça va bien ça a
toujours bien et t il comment avez vous
compris ses paroles j'ai compris qu'il
était content d'être arrêté parce que
les gens de l'hôtel voulait les gorges
et c'est bien ce que vous vouliez dire
je n'ai aucun souvenir de tout cela mme
sur président mais il est évident que
les derniers propos cités par le témoin
ça va bien ça toujours bien et éprouvent
mais par leur non sens même que et
quinine savait plus ce qu'il disait sa
mâchoire balbutier avez vous dit c'est
une image hardy mais elle exprime bien
les bêtises de l'accusé à ce moment là
monsieur le président je voudrais poser
une dernière question témoin
pose là m quelle heure est il lorsque
vous avez arrêté l'accusé pouvait être 4
heures du matin alors il y avait une
heure et demie environ que le crime
avait été comme dia lorsque vous avez
emmené et qui nous au commissariat avez
vous laissé un agent de police sur les
lieux du crime
non voilà messieurs les jurés
voilà par la négligence du témoin il n'y
avait aucun représentant de la loi dans
la chambre du crime entre 4 et 5 heures
du matin à 5h en effet le commissaire de
police est enfin arrivé et bien pendant
sept heures les gens de l'hôtel on
l'avait la chambre frotter les parquets
effaçant toutes les empreintes ils ont
fait la toilette des corps ils ont même
jetés pêle mêle dans un seul sac tous
les nageurs ensanglanté les draps les
chemises des victimes et même celle de
équine et voilà messieurs les jurés
comment grâce aux témoins l'instruction
a été faussée au départ commissaire de
police l'a reconnu lui-même il a déclaré
quand je suis arrivé le mal était fait
vous pouvez vous retirer le témoin
suivant galonnés charles 45 ans employée
d'hôtel étant le beau frère de madame du
bikini vous ne pouvez prêter serment
mais je vous jure de dire toute la
vérité
vous êtes le concierge de l'hôtel de
l'europe
oui monsieur le président dans la nuit
du 12 au 13 novembre toutes les portes
de l'hôtel était bien fermé les thèmes
chez le président vous en êtes sûr
absolument la petite porte de la cuisine
qui donne sur la cour n'est jamais
fermée tu le sais bien
oui mais comment on peut pas rentrer
dans la cour mais si on le peut en
passant par dessus le mur aucune trace
n'a été relevée sur le mur ni dans la
cour derrière voyons hazuki parce que le
commissaire de police vous a demandé
quelques heures après le crime si
quelqu'un avait pu s'introduire dans la
chambre de votre femme vous lui avez
répondu que c'était tout à fait
impossible en effet je les dis mais ce
n'est pas fini de répondre à cette
question
c'est au commissaire de police at on
fouillait l'hôtel no on a choisi la
solution la plus favorable à la paresse
de l'instruction et qui était là on
l'arrêté c'était plus commode et
maintenant lui reproche d'avoir dit que
personne ne pouvait pénétrer dans la
chambre de sa femme
ce n'est pas aisé qui ni d'expliquer ce
qui s'est passé c'est à l'accusation
d'apporter les preuves de la culpabilité
j'ai fait une ronde à 2 heures du matin
cette nuit là je n'ai rien remarqué
d'anormal
je regrette que le commissaire de police
se soit contenté de cette ronde
c'est donc une demi heure à peine après
avoir fait cette ronde
je vous avais entendu les cris des
victimes non non non non j'ai pas
entendu écrit j'ai entendu cecchini qui
m'appelait du couloir quand je suis
rentré dans la chambre j'ai croisé mofaz
qui ont porté la petite équipe m'a dit
on a assassiné ma femme et césarine
appel vite un médecin alors je suis
allée téléphoner quand je suis revenue
cecchini m'a dit où on vit de la porte
d'en bas que j'ai dû prévenir la police
zecchini votre femme vive est elle
encore lorsque vous avez décidé d'aller
prévenir la police oui monsieur le
président comment avez vous pu laisser
la mourante
comment avez vous pu la quitter pour
prévenir la police il suffisait de
téléphoner d'envoyer quelqu'un
pourquoi avez vous tenu à y aller vous
mène lancé rien non vraiment je ne peux
pas vous expliquer je ne je ne sais pas
réessayer
non je n'en sais rien n'était ce pas
parce que vous aviez l'intention de vous
livrer à la police
n'éprouvez-vous pas le besoin de dire
j'ai tué ma femme j'ai tué ma fille
arrêtez moi je suis innocent je le jure
alors pourquoi être voilés vous même au
commissariat
pourquoi avez vous laissez votre femme
mourir seul
je ne pensais pas qu'elle allait mourir
aussi vite
et puis je n'ai pas laissé seul mon beau
frère était là soit
avez vous pu interroger la victime après
le départ de l'accusé je lui ai demandé
mais quitte à frapper
elle m'a répondu tu le sais bien
ballonnements veut la mort monsieur le
président le sauver de la misère et
c'était lui qui intéressent et ma femme
contre moi il veut ma tête voilà ce
qu'il veut êtes vous sûr d'avoir entendu
puis le sait bien elle a murmuré mais
j'en suis sûr en quelle langue
la victime vous êtes elle répondu en
piémontais comment dit-on tu le sais
bien piémontais massa semaine
et comment dit-on je n'en sais rien
machine n mahsas ben tu le sais bien
masai non je n'en sais rien et malgré la
similitude de ces deux expressions vous
pouvez affirmer la réponse ayant été
murmuré vous pouvez affirmer que la
victime vous a bien dit mahsas ben tu le
sais bien
et non ma sai meme je n'en sais rien je
crois qu'elle m'a dit nasa ce ben tu le
sais bien
vous le croyez où vous l'affirmer je le
crois oui je crois
madame zecchini natel plus rien dit
après cela je me souviens pas alors je
vais vous aider vous avez déclaré au
commissariat de police
juste avant de mourir ma belle sur a
murmuré jeunes sais rien l'esm à mourir
mais pour vos enfants c'est impossible
et c'est vous même qui avait rapporté
ses parents le commissariat de police
est formel monsieur le président vous
reprochez à zecchini d'avoir abandonné
sa femme pour aller prévenir la police
mais s'il était coupable il serait resté
près d'elle jusqu'à ce qu'elle meure
jusqu'à ce qu'elle ne puisse plus rien
révélé
s'il était coupable il aurait envoyé son
beau-frère prévenir la police il serait
resté près de la victime jusqu'à ce
qu'elles ne puissent le rien à dire
vous déclarez votre plus de bars les
maîtres n'en sommes encore qu'aux débats
lorsque vous êtes entré pour la première
fois dans la chambre de la victime
lorsque vous avez compris comment votre
belle soeur et sa fille avaient été
assassinés avez-vous pensé à chercher
l'armé du crime
oui mais j'ai pas trouvé tu ose se dire
que tu l'as cherché j'ai bien vu qu'il y
avait un couteau dans la chambre vous
êtes certain d'avoir constaté cette
absence de couteau chez l'humain je vous
pose cette question parce qu'on peut se
demander si une personne mal
intentionnée n'a pas cherché à prendre
ce couteau pour le cacher sous le buffet
du salon afin de rendre invraisemblable
tout
hypothèse de suicide il n'y avait aucun
couteau dans la chambre je puis vous
l'affirmez l'espace chez vous comme adam
zecchini a passé la soirée du 12
novembre
oui elle est venue nous voir ma femme et
moi après le dîner elle est restée fou
pour une heure environ
elle était très troublée vous ôtez le
dit pourquoi elle avait peur de quoi
va-t-elle peur elle avait peur d'être
assassiné par lui pourquoi mais il y
avait fait une scène terrible l'après
midi c'est faux monsieur le président
nous avons eu une discussion simplement
qu'elle propose 200 élus lieu offre
toujours la même chose elle voulait
divorcer lui voulait pas pourquoi vous
le thème divorcer parce que j'en avais
assez de la vie qui me faisait mener n'a
pas plu à voir que lui tenez moi ou deux
ans il m'a pas offert un verre de vin
même à noël depuis demandé un peu aux
clients ils découpent et lui-même les
tranches de viande dans la cuisine pour
qu'elle soit bien ce but puis sa femme
c'était la même chose je ne pouvais rien
j'étais poêle y apporte plus à l'arc lui
l'appui ils abattaient monsieur le
président il abattait du mangalore comme
je t'ai vu la chefferie je t'ai vu la
traînée par terre
il n'en veut monsieur le président parce
que j'ai voulu le chasser de l'hôtel et
c'est ma femme qui a voulu garder un
mariage et le sens de la famille ah je
pense bien j'avais toute la famille sur
les bras tous les avions et soeurs les
maritonnes vous dites que l'accusé
battait sa femme
ceci a été confirmé par d'autres témoins
à l'instruction mais oui la battait
c'est une brute et ma belle soeur était
une dame une jolie dame est ce seulement
pour cet ensemble de raisons que la
victime voulait divorcer je n'en vois
pas d'autre vraiment vraiment ne l'avez
vous pas entendu dire l'accusé je n'ai
pas besoin de ton argent j'ai quelqu'un
qui ment donnera c'est exact je lui ai
entendu dire ça qui était si quelqu un
je ne sais rien moi monsieur le
président mais nous reviendrons plus
tard sur ce point g qui nie vous
reconnaissez que votre femme voulait
divorcer elle en parle et quelquefois
quand elle était en colère je ne la
croyait si bien qu'il ne vivait plus
depuis qu'elle était allée voir un
avocat
il faisait une vie d'enfer depuis ce
jour-là but du ch était là quand elle
est revenue chez l'avocat
elle lui a dit si je pars j'aurai la
moitié des hôtels palette est effondré
ils ne savaient pas pourtant bien que
vous étiez mariés sous le régime de la
communauté
bien entendu monsieur oui ils étaient
mariés sous le régime de la loi
française et il croyait que la loi
française était comme la loi italienne
qui donne trois caveaux mari et un quart
à la femme mais quand il a su que la loi
française donne la moitié alain la
moitié à l'autre mais il est devenu fou
furieux mais ceux qui voulaient pas
perdre la moitié de sa fortune mais il
hérisse vous savez il en immeuble à nice
qui vomit sur 1000 francs et l'hôtel
marche bien mais c'est pour ça qu'il
voulait pas divorcer
j'ai fini ignorions que la loi française
accorde la moitié des biens à chacun des
deux conjoints
je l'ignorais en effet est-ce parce que
votre femme parlait à nouveau de
divorcer que vous êtes vous êtes disputé
avec elle dans l'après-midi du 12
novembre
on ne s'est pas disputé moss est
président moteur ne tient encore
tremplin quand elle est arrivée chez
nous elle avait peur d'être assassiné
par tous elle me l'a dit et la verve et
sentiments elle avait peur de toi
n'est ce pas vous qui avait conseillé à
la dame de faire chambre à part
riise - garonne quant à kimi est revenue
du commissariat de police il était
accompagné de deux agents
vous n'avez vous rien dire l'un d'eux je
me souviens pas vous lui avez dit
désignant l'accusé c'est lui qui a fait
le coup ça c'est exact et quand saviez
vous j'en étais sûr comme j'en suis sûr
maintenant à alors si j'ai vraiment
compris la déposition du témoin l'accusé
aurait tué sa femme par intérêt pour ne
pas perdre en divorçant la moitié de ces
biens c'est ça oui votre explication ne
tient pas si les épouses et qu'il n'y
avait divorcé zecchini nauru a partagé
aucun c'est bien car madame et qui
n'aurait perdu le divorce
et vous savez très bien pourquoi nancy
parce que c'est in y avait la preuve de
son la fortune monsieur le président
vous avez cette preuve au dossier
oui m mais vous n'avez pas le droit
d'affirmer que madame zecchini eut perdu
le divorce
voulant savait rien brutalité de
l'accusé était une charge lourde que
l'infidélité de son infortuné campagne
c'est une lettre adressée m chez victor
sita poste restante nice et qui ni
comment vous êtes vous procurer cette
lettre j'avais surpris ma femme sans
qu'elle s'en aperçoit pendant qu'elle
écrivait je la laissais le vert et le
soir je suis allé à la gare et j'ai dit
que j'avais jeté par erreur une lettre
dans la boîte on a ouvert la boîte sur
une enveloppe
j'ai reconnu l'écriture de ma femme les
prises voici cette lettre mon adoré et
bien aimé lutter comment as tu passé à
fait
je suis désolé de te savoir loin de moi
zecs ligne et se doute de quelque chose
mon victor est il possible de t'oublier
je suis toujours près de toi cette
lettre et qu'ils me l'aviez déposé dans
votre coffre à la banque
pourquoi donc qu'on ne puisse pas me la
voler et pourquoi y tenir ou temps
peut-être en prévision d'un divorce
n'était ce pas plutôt à prévision de ce
qui vous arrive aujourd'hui
n'était ce pas plutôt pour votre défense
non monsieur le président avant de la
déposer à la banque que j'avais écrit
quelques mots sur l' enveloppe quelques
mots qui réponde à cette question je lis
cette phrase écrite de votre main je ne
vais rien faire car je ne veux pas me
ruiner
je ne veux rien faire
qu'entendez vous par là je ne veux pas
tuer je ne veux pas divorcer je n'ai
jamais pensé à tuer ma femme je ne vais
rien faire
signifiait donc je ne veux pas divorcer
en effet je ne voulait pas divorcer pour
ne pas vous ruiner
vous le dites vous êtes donc d'accord
avec le témoin sur ce point vous ne
vouliez pas divorcer votre femme elle le
souhaitait vous le reconnaissez
je reconnais qu'elle était allée voir un
avocat sous le conseil du témoin car il
a tout essayé pour briser mon ménage
quel sentiment éprouvez vous pour votre
femme je les mets moi je n'avais pas de
liaison j'avais qu'une femme qu'elle
vous y trompez n'avait pas modifié aux
sentiments à son égard les jamais eu de
n pour ma femme
s'occuper de la maison et les mais bien
les enfants je vous remercie vous pouvez
vous retire le témoin suivant cadeaux
raymond 17 ans groome à l'hôtel de
l'europe
depuis combien de temps travaillez vous
à l'hôtel de l'europe depuis deux ans
monsieur le président vous est il arrivé
d'assister à des disputes entre madame
acquis ni et son mari le plus souvent il
se traitait de voleur et mutuellement
oui chacun son tour monsieur rouspéter
parce que madame ne marquait pas tout
sur le livre de contes ces discussions
et des telles violences
plutôt oui j'ai vu monsieur giflé madame
pour 10 francs
tu as vu ça toi pouvais je les ai vus
voulangis à l'hôtel oui monsieur le
président quel vais vous fait dans la
nuit du 12 au 13 novembre
j'ai été réveillée comme tout le monde
quand je suis arrivé dans la chambre je
me suis occupé du petit pepino qui droit
sur son lit à regarder tout ce massacre
je les emmener avec moi messieurs les
jurés je requiers toute votre attention
le témoin à l'instruction a fait une
déposition très grave
voulez-vous la répéter c'est un mois phr
le petit pepino m'a dit c'est terrible
il m'a dit pourquoi pas pâti fait du
chocolat rouge avec le bras de césarine
l'horreur de cette phrase messieurs les
jurés je la ressens aussi intensément
vous
qu'un enfant de trois ans est plus
prononcé ces mots rend plus odieux
encore ce double assassinat mais parce
que cette phrase est terrible et
particulièrement grave pour l'accusé mon
devoir est d'établir les circonstances
dans lesquelles elle a été entendue par
le témoin à quel moment le petit pepino
vous at il posé cette question
le lendemain matin quand je suis allé le
voir où était-il chez monsieur gallone m
vous osé accuser le beau frère de madame
zecchini d'avoir dicté cette phrase à
cet enfant ce sera au jury de se poser
cette question monsieur le président
c'est un sens chez vous pouvez vous
retirer des mois suivants
pirelli marguerite femme de chambre vous
êtes services de l'accusé c'était plutôt
service de madame c'est madame qui
dirigeait le personnel êtes vous au
courant de disputes qui éclataient entre
eux
tout le monde était au courant monsieur
le président soufflez clients bien
entendu qu était la réputation de
l'accusé en a qui l'aimaient bien là
qu'il n'aimait pas vous précisez votre
réponse il y avait deux clans gallone et
détesté monsieur madame elle détestait
le nouveau comptable
parce que le nouveau comptable montrer
trop les comptes à monsieur auquel que
l'on appartenez-vous moi j'aime bien
monsieur je me bien madame aussi si ce
gars là n'est pas ce qui brouille les
cartes
c'est à cause de lui que monsieur madame
se disputait souvent car vous vous dites
madame soit la patronne je n'ai fait
part au juge d'instruction d'une
conversation que vous avez eue avec le
petit pepino cette déposition et
particulier en europe
je vous supplie ne pas la répéter
si vous n'êtes pas absolument certaine
d'avoir dit la vérité
j'ai dit la vérité monsieur le président
oui le petit pepino m'a dit c'est papa
qui a tué maman je suis demandé tu l'as
vu il m'a répondu non
si ma tante qui me l'a dit la tenante de
papineau à madame garonne n'est ce pas
oui monsieur le président je vous
remercie vous pouvez vous retire fait
entrer madame gallone vous êtes la soeur
de la victime vous ne pouvez donc pas
près des siens mais je vous demande vous
le jure de dire toute la vérité je la
dirai monsieur le président c'est à vous
que le petit pepino a été confiée la
nuit même du crime
oui monsieur le président c'est bien
naturel puisque je suis sa tante quand
l'avez-vous interrogé pour la première
fois ce n'est pas moi qui lui ai posé la
question je vous demande quand
l'avez-vous interrogé pour la première
fois le lendemain vous êtes sûr que ce
n'est pas la nuit même du crime
oh non monsieur le président au le
pauvre petit pleurait quand on l'a amené
vous pensez il avait trois ans il
pleurait tant qu'on ne pouvait pas
parler ça n'aurait pas été humains de le
questionner elle s'avoue en premier que
le petit pepino a parlé des événements
de la nuit
non c'était cadeau cadeaux est le témoin
qui a rapporté la terrible accusation de
peppino mais c'est le juré pape a fait
du chocolat rouge avec le bras de ses
armes parce que vous avez appris que
votre serbe venait d'être assassiné
avez-vous pensé comme votre mari que
l'accusé était coupable
sur le moment j'ai pensé oh malheur
après oui j'ai pensé comme mon mari
aviez-vous déjà cette conviction la
première fois que vous avez interrogé le
petit pinault je ne sais plus êtes vous
sûr de ne pas avoir sans le vouloir fait
partager votre conviction petit pepino
j'en suis sûr absolument vous n'avez
jamais dit à cet enfant - sa présence
que son père était l'assassin jamais je
jure
pour quelles raisons pensiez-vous que
l'accusé des coupes à un jour qu'ils se
disputaient tous les deux dans la
cuisine j'ai vu zecchini brandir un
couteau en disant c'est comme ça que tu
finiras cette femme me détestent
monsieur le président je t'ai vu le
faire comme je te vois maintenant tu
mens on me perds je dis la vérité avant
d'entendre les trois derniers témoins
peut-être est-il bon de faire le point
l'accusation dit personne sauf zecchini
n'a pu entrer dans la chambre 32
on se souvient que les portes étaient
fermées à clé n'ont pas été forcés quant
à la fenêtre qui donne sur le couloir un
grillage la protège qu'on ne peut
soulever que de l'intérieur
ce qui revient à dire encore une fois
seul et qu'il n'y a pu entrer dans la
chambre
le plus surprenant est que la défense
semble partager cette conviction le
choix est donc restreint s'il ya eu
assassinat cecchini qui rase à saint cyr
et qui n'y est innocent c'est que madame
zecchini s'est suicidé terriblement
restreint son choix un médecin dira s'il
est possible ou non que madame zecchini
se soit suicidé mais le plus difficile à
admettre sera dans ce cas la mort de
césar hymne aux ratons supposer que
madame et qui n'y est plus par désespoir
tué sa fille avant de se tuer elle même
peut-on supposer un tel acte et surtout
et tiny a paraît-il à ces innocents pour
que l'on ose prêté à la victime une si
grande folie
les objections sont nombreuses
la plus forte étant la terrible phrase
du petit pepino va pas a fait du
chocolat rouge avec le bras de césarine
et puis ce couteau retrouvé à 20 mètres
de la chambre sans doute quelqu'un peut
y avoir mis dans ce cas le suicide
aurait été camouflés en crime par un
ennemi 2 et qui nie c'est là bien sûr
une hypothèse mais les lacunes de
l'instruction sont aussi grande qu'on
rencontre dans cette affaire beaucoup
plus l'hypothèse que de preuves le
meurtre de ces arts ina quel que soit le
choix que vous ferez est difficile à
expliquer pourquoi et qui n'y aurait-il
tué sa fille pourquoi zecchini at il tué
sa fille par folie par méprise je vous
rappelle que madame zecchini cette
nuit-là avait pris dans le lit la place
généralement occupés par ces arts ina
les deux témoins suivants ne vont pas
nous donner certes la clé du mystère
mais ils vont nous parler objectivement
de l'accusé et de la victime
leurs propos même si la croissance notre
incertitudes nous permettront de mieux
comprendre le couple zecchini martinez
etienne 50 ans depuis combien de temps
connaissez-vous l'accusé cela fait douze
ans monsieur le président j'avais
fournis en vins et liqueurs depuis 1916
et je suis devenu peu à peu son ami ou
plutôt leurs amis car madame zecchini on
aurait également de son amitié et vous
avez réussi à rester jusqu'au jour du
crime
l'amie de l'un et de l'autre non madame
zecchini savais que j'étais au courant
de ses infidélités et cela devait la
gêne et sans doute
enfin bref elles ne m'invitait pas comme
autrefois partagé leur repas
est-ce l'accusé qui vous avait parlé de
son
poutine oui bien sûr il en souffrait
beaucoup trop pour une femme en parler
il en souffrait comment dire
furieusement un jour il m'a dit j'ai
failli tout massacrer je me suis retenu
à cause des enfants car il aimait
beaucoup ses enfants et c'est affreux à
dire mais c'est la petite césarine qui
était sa préférée en effet affreux en
temps vous dites qu'ils ne souffraient
furieusement de son infortune
entendez vous par là et qu'il était
obsédé par sa jalousie
ce n'est pas si si simple que cela
naturellement il est jaloux à se rendre
malade même jour il m'a montré son
carnet j'ai lu mardi
ma femme a embrassé le comptable
mercredi ma femme a caressé le comptable
certes cela peut faire sourire qu'à
comptable n'est pas forcément un donjon
mai et qui nient aimait sa femme
physiquement je ne lui ai jamais connu
une aventure et depuis que madame et qui
n'y avaient décidé de faire son bras pas
il n'était plus le même
ainsi il y avait la jalousie mais il y
avait autre chose qui est plus difficile
à expliquer
vous le savez monsieur le président
quand et qui me racontait sa femme il
était garçon boucher il a travaillé dur
c'est une brute au travail
il a réussi mais il est resté aussi
âpres au gain contre x bref il n'a pas
changé sa femme elle avait changé on ne
pouvait pas deviner qu'elle avait été
femme de chambre et elle avait un peu
honte de lui elle l'humiliait ainsi en
plus d'être jaloux il se sentait humilié
quand on lui refusait sa place dans le
lit conjugal
voilà je crois ce qui les sépare est ce
parce qu'ils provoquaient les scènes de
ménages la famille de madame jacqueline
et n'était elle pas aussi une occasion
de disputes
si monsieur et madame galonnés
particulièrement zecchini avait voulu
les faire partir mais sa femme s'y était
opposé il était resté il sentait
l'hôtellerie chapaize et sa femme
préféré s'occuper de tout ge est il
parlait de leur divorce éventuelles il
ne voulait pas divorcer
pourquoi il ne voulait pas courir le
risque de perdre la moitié de ses biens
espérait-il reconquérir sa femme oui il
m'avait dit plusieurs fois quand je
réfléchis mon beau frère à la porte ma
femme me reviendra il était convaincu
que galonnés était son mauvais génie
l'accusé ne nous a rien dit qu'ils aient
pu le faire redouter un malheur non
jamais n'avez-vous pas rendu visite à
l'accusé
si je n'ai quitté quelques heures avant
le crime
de quoi avez vous parlé de tout et de
rien de sa femme de nos affaires il
était tout à fait calme
il m'a même confié qu'il avait
l'intention d'acheter une voiture pour
aller se promener le dimanche avec ses
enfants gallone ne vous at il pas
demandé d'accabler cecchini je les
rencontrais dans l'antichambre du juge
d'instruction
il m'a dit vous savez ce que vous avez à
dire
défendez notre cause je vous remercie
le témoin suivant hélène clément entière
48 ans veuillez faire votre déposition
j'ai habité pendant deux années de suite
à l'hôtel de l'europe
je les quittait le lendemain du crime je
voulais plus rester vous comprendre
madame ce qui était devenu votre ami
louis nous bavardions très souvent
toutes les deux c'était une femme très
gai lorsqu'elle n'était pas trop
malheureuse que faisait-elle ce
confidences naturellement c'était un
homme beaucoup trop fruste pour elle il
la battait elle me montrer ses bleus
mais ce qui la rendait le plus furieuse
c'était son avarice
il lui donnait jamais un sou
elle aimait sortir danser se promener
lui non il n'avait pas les mêmes goûts
se disputent de thil souvent au
plusieurs fois par jour elle n'en
pouvait plus elle voulait divorcer
d'ailleurs mais lui ne voulait pas celle
à désespérer car ce ne sont pas les
prétendants qui lui auraient manqué ne
vous parle tel de ce prétendant du
secrètement mais ses soupirs en disait
long
elle était exaspérée surtout ces
derniers temps nous était jamais rien
dit qu'il peut vous faire douter de ce
fait un acte de désespoir elle parlait
quelques fois de se suicider mais
c'était seulement lorsqu'elle était très
abattu ce qui l'inquiétait c'était son
mari elle me répétait depuis que césar
il est rentré vous savez qu'elle faisait
coucher la pauvre petite dans son lit
depuis que césarine est rentré je ne
sais pas ce quasi king mais tous les
soirs il marche dans le couloir il va il
vient il tourne
il me fait peur est vraiment vraiment
elle avait peur
vous comprenez elle ne voulait plus de
lui
elle se serait tu es sûrement plutôt que
de le recevoir dans son lit ou l'hôtel
des deux fois je vous remercie
le témoin suivant
giraud gaston 40 ans médecin légiste
ces volontaires qui avaient procédé à
l'inspection du corps des victimes
oui monsieur le président et je dois
dire que même pour un médecin habitué à
voir des choses affreuses
le spectacle n'était pas supportable
c'était une boucherie plus qu'un
assassinat l'hémorragie avait été si
importante que les deux corps était
complètement exsangue de calcul sur
madame et qu'il n'y est elle morte
s'il est difficile de répondre la
victime ait été frappée mortellement une
fois au ventre une fois la poitrine
madame zecchini at elle été frappée
mortellement pendant son sommeil nous
donc d'après la direction des blessures
on doit penser qu'elles étaient deux
bouts lorsqu'elle a été frappée
est il possible que madame zecchini se
soit suicidé c'est possible oui mais un
vraisemblable étant donné la direction
des coûts leur violence et leur nombre
enfin j'ai relevé des blessures sur son
avant-bras droit affirmé
pouvez-vous affirmer docteur que madame
zecchini ne se soit pas suicidé
médicalement je ne peux pas l'affirmer
rien n'est impossible
si madame zecchini c'est frappé la
première fois au vendre la plus frappé
ensuite à la poitrine mais dans ce cas
je demande qu'on m'explique les
blessures faites à l'avant-bras pas de
questions monsieur l'avocat général
non
et vous m oui monsieur le président vous
avez examiner le linge des victimes
que vous a révélé cet examen j'ai
examiné la chemise de nuit que portait
madame zecchini la nuit du crime
je n'ai trouvé qu'une seule déchirure
correspondant à la blessure faite à la
poitrine
aucune déchirure ne correspondait à la
blessure faite aux ventes
non on doit donc supposer madame
zecchini ayant été tués deux bouts que
la chemise de nuit a été relevé par le
meurtrier
je ferai remarquer messieurs les jurés
combien il est invraisemblable qu'un
assassin relève la chemise de sa victime
avant de la frapper
par contre le geste semble tout naturel
s'il est accompli par quelqu'un qui veut
se suicider je remercie docteur le rôle
de l'avocat général n'est pas
d'accumuler des charges facile contre
l'accusé mais de fournir des preuves
nous devons donc nous demander s'il
existe des preuves de la culpabilité de
l'accusé
des objections multiples et troublante
m'ont été faites des scrupules
respectables ont été apportées les
experts ont pu se tromper
après avoir déclaré à l'instruction
l'hypothèse d'un suicide est à rejeter
formellement le docteur giro a fini par
dire aux débats il n'est pas
vraisemblable que madame zecchini et
puces tués et vraisemblance messieurs
les jurés ne peuvent suffire à la
justice l'examen des lieux ne permettait
là aucune conclusion
tout a été bouleversée à la suite d'une
indulgence regrettable des policiers
interrogé avec insistance même et qui
nient qui gardait toute sa conscience
n'a pas voulu dire le nom de l'assassin
quitté assassiné lui demande gallone
elle répond soit je n'en sais rien soit
tu le sais bien mais un peu plus tard
elle dit je ne sais rien les soit mourir
mais pauvre enfant
cette dernière phrase seul n'est pas
équivoque c'est elle qu'il faut retenir
il reste les propos les violences et
disputes rapportés par gallone
mégatonnes des tests l'accusé il s'est
acharné contre lyon point de violer la
loi alors l'accusation s'effondre tel
nom une preuve subsiste accablante
c'est la terrible phrase que le petit
baby do a dit aux témoins cadeau le
matin qu'a suivi le drame
pourquoi pape at il fait du chocolat
rouge avec le brad césarine l'enfant
n'avait vu personne gallone ne lui avait
pas encore parlé les inquiétudes de ma
conscience sont féroces j'ai rejeté tout
ce qui n'était pas certain il reste
cette question posée par pepino il nous
reste à trouver les motifs du drame
on a dit que c'est qu'il n'y avait tué
sa fille par erreur qu'il y avait eu
méprise la fille occupant la place
habituellement occupée par la femme
cette thèse est peu compatible avec la
présence d'une veilleuse dans la chambre
vous dirais-je maintenant qu'elle est ma
conviction profonde messieurs les jurés
le crime est l'aboutissement d'un drame
d'alcôve auquel l'enfant a été mêlé
accidentellement
c'est une manoeuvre maladroite de la mer
traqué qui qui a perdu césarine les
griefs de lucchini contre sa femme était
de trois sortes il acceptait mal comme
l'abs et qui n'y est une autorité
prépondérante dans l'hôtel ils
ignoraient jusqu'à ces derniers temps
les conséquences du régime matrimonial
qu'il avait accepté enfin il y avait la
main ou plutôt les amants zecchini
adorait sa femme physiquement elle était
belle et désirable
sa femme le pensait et se dérobait à ces
étreintes pour éviter les caresses
détester elle faisait coucher césarine
dans son lit elle même n'a t'elle pas
confessé depuis que césarine et ici on
mari ne tient plus en place
la nuit se lève plusieurs fois il marche
dans le couloir comme un fou c'était
bien vrai messieurs les jurés zecchini
était fou il n'avait pas de liaison lui
n'avait que sa femme et ce sont les
refus prémédité et successives de cette
femme qui ont fait de l'hôtelier
un criminel quelle preuve d' assassinat
nous a tant apporté aucune
on ne veut parler de préméditation car
préméditation signifie préparation c'est
qu'il y aurait alors ménager sa fuite
qu'elle vient il au contraire ils
appellent au secours il se rend au
commissariat de police
il se livre il y a eu meurtre parce que
sinon on peut condamner un homme sur des
présomptions des bavardages les paroles
du petit pepino désigne irréfutablement
son père comme le meurtrier
mais il n'y a pas eu assassiné ainsi que
le définit le code et l'assassinât sol
est puni de mort
madame zecchini est morte sans une
plainte
il vous manque les preuves qui vous
permettrait d'envoyer un homme vers
l'échafaud que votre délibération soit
impartial mais anxieuse dans la sérénité
au soir de ma carrière
je vous donne ce que je pense
j'ai à défendre l'homme le plus
malheureux que j'ai rencontré dans ma
carrière messieurs les jurés je lutte
contre une opinion public surchauffé
passionné d'une façon inquiétante à
doute terrible plane sur cette affaire
ce doute vient des lacunes de
l'instruction de l'absence de
vérification de conservation souvenez
vous des premières déclarations deux
équipes
j'ai entendu des cris provenant de la
chambre de ma femme je me suis
précipitée elle me cria l'assassin et
dans le vestibule je m'élançais je ne
vit rien je rentrais dans la chambre je
m'aperçus que ma femme et ma fille était
blessé
j'ai dit au portier téléphone le docteur
et je suis venu avertir la police
le portier ses galons il souffle à
l'oreille d'un agent cees et qui nie
l'assassin cette parole va être le point
de départ d'une sorte de sujétion
collective à peine ouverte
l'instruction est terminée on trouve le
couteau qui a servi aux meurtriers
le juge ne fait pas relever les
empreintes digitales qui doivent se
trouver sur larmes quelques jours après
le drame dans le couloir face à la porte
de la chambre de la victime à hauteur de
la main on remarque sur la porte d'un
placard des gouttelettes de sang autour
d'une entaille fait part à couteau
le juge négligent de s'attarder à ce
détail l'hypothèse de l'assassinât par
un meurtrier venues du dehors semblaient
susceptibles de ne pas être écartée
l'hôtel de l'europe étant ouvert de jour
et de nuit est cependant aucune
vérification d'identité n'a été fait
on n'a pas cherché à savoir qu'il y
avait dans l'hôtel quels étaient les
clients quels étaient les employés enfin
messieurs les jurés on recueille le
témoignage du plus jeune fils de c'est
inné le petit pepino âgée de trois ans
sur cette chose si fragile qu'est le
témoignage d'un enfant et sur cette
chose sol monsieur l'avocat général
conclut à une condamnation
mais comment légalement les déclarations
d'un enfant peuvent elles servir de base
à une condamnation
maintenant je reviendrai au fait une
dernière fois et qu'il y avait du sang
sur ses vêtements mais parce qu'il avait
transporté sa femme de son lit sur le
divan coupable il aurait fait
disparaître ces tâches coupable il
aurait fait le vide autour de sa femme
pour éviter qu'elle ne le dénonce à
quelles preuves avez-vous de la
culpabilité de l'accusé
comment pourrait-on condamnés et qu'ils
nient après une telle carence de la
justice après de telles erreurs
messieurs les jurés
il ne vous reste qu'un choix a quitté
pour ne pas courir le risque d'une
erreur judiciaire
je suis les jurés weill est entrée dans
la chambre des délibérations
l'audience est suspendue aussi forte que
puisse être votre envie de ne pas
répondre à la question et qui n'y est il
coupable d'avoir assassiné sa femme et
sa fille il faut vous décider maintenant
votre question s'agit-il d'un meurtre ou
d'un crime
y at il une préméditation monsieur le
chef du jury veuillez faire connaître à
la cour le résultat de vos délibérations
sur mon honneur et ma conscience devant
dieu et devant les hommes
la déclaration du jury est la suivante à
la question cecchini est il coupable du
meurtre de sa femme et de sa fille
césarine la réponse est oui
l'accusé bénéficie des circonstances a
tellement j'ai faites entrer l'accusé
cecchini la cour après en avoir délibéré
les réponses du jury au condamne à vingt
ans de travaux forcés après cassation il
y eut un second procès zecchini pris
deux nouveaux avocats et la thèse de la
défense fut tout à fait différente
la phrase du petit pepino fut rejetée
par les défenseurs qui n'acceptait pas
la déposition d'un enfant de trois ans
et l'accusation renonça à ceux qui dans
le premier procès avait été considéré
par l'avocat général comme la seule
preuve de culpabilité de l'accusé autre
modification importante
maître henri torres défenseurs 2 et qui
nie dans ce second procès prouve à lui
même qu'il était possible malgré le
grillage d'entrer dans la chambre où
furent assassinés madame zecchini et sa
fille le crime pouvait donc avoir été
commis par un assassin venus de
l'extérieur
bien sûr de cet assassin on ne savait
rien mais qui la faute
l'instruction avait été si mal fait que
l'hôtel n'avait pas même été fouillé par
la police après le crime
malgré ces deux nouveaux points et qui
n'y fut condamné mais cette fois à dix
ans de travaux forcés seulement dix ans
de travaux forcés écrit m henri torres
ce verdict ne traduit-il pas la
certitude anxieuse le trouble de l'âme
de ceux qui l'ont rendue n'est-il pas le
résultat d'une transaction entre le juge
et sa conscience qu'il le semble en
effet du bagne de cayenne où il fut
transféré zecchini réussit à s'évader il
regagna son pays natal l'italie et
ouvrir un restaurant
peut-être avez-vous dîner chez lui
[Musique]